hi Matt here before we start our latest
episode we wanted to let you know that
we now have a think fast talk smart the
newsletter we'll provide bonus content
additional materials like articles and
videos previews of future topics and
behind the scenes information please
sign up at
stanford.io
TF TS newsletter again stanford.io slash
tfts newsletter also join us on
Instagram we started a new account think
fast talk smart follow us there just
like you follow us on LinkedIn when we
think about the words we use we tend to
focus on making sure we communicate our
meaning but in fact communicating
information about our relationship our
connection
might be even more important
I'm Matt Abrahams and I teach strategic
communication at Stanford Graduate
School of Business welcome to think fast
talk smart the podcast
today I look forward to speaking with
Valerie Friedland Valerie is a professor
of sociolinguistics at the University of
Nevada in Reno she is an expert on the
relationship between language and
society and recently released her new
book entitled like literally dude
arguing for the good and bad English
welcome Valerie I am super excited to
dive into our conversation today
well thanks Matt I'm really excited to
talk with you great and I love that I
just get to say dude like I used to say
growing up in Northern California near
Santa Cruz I'd like to get started with
a high level question what is the
purpose of language and how does it
relate to and reveal Who We Are
the purpose of language is really
twofold it's about communication of
information so I have a message and I
want you to have the same message in
your head and that requires that I
somehow get it to you and the best way
to do that is speech but the second is
social we don't just talk to transmit
information and so it's not just the
message in my head strictly into your
head it's also my feelings about the
message in my head my feelings about our
relationship and my sense of how welcome
this information might be to you so all
these different factors enter into
communication so language is about how
we encode both the linguistic message
and that social message it really has
two elements the information and the
connection as well and we have to be
mindful of that for sure I have like
lots of detailed questions to ask so
let's get into them can you talk about
the power of the word like and the power
of the word so so I see these creeping
in everywhere absolutely and I think a
lot of them are thought of as crutch
words or words that are not necessary
but really they're not at all the verbal
riffraff that people assign to them they
are really valuable and they both have
Arisen to serve a need and everything
that we use in language comes in because
it has a function that maybe some people
don't value or they have a different way
of meeting that need but then the
speakers that bring in those Innovations
clearly are finding a need for it and
like is a perfect example of that like
has a bunch of different purposes and
historically has been in the language a
long time so we find verb like obviously
it was more like Lis at the time but
that comes in around the 12th century
into English and gradually over time by
the time we hit the 15th and 16th
century all of a sudden light could be a
preposition and light could be a
conjunction that doesn't mean we always
like the new forms of those speech
features and even conjunction like is
still thought of as being incorrect In
grammar books so if you look at
contemporary grammar Books A lot of
times they'll tell you do not use like
as a conjunction it's just sort of an
example of how these forms shift over
time we often don't like them when
they're doing it but the newest forms of
like are ones that are not directly
related to the literal meaning of a
sentence and I think that's why people
have a lot of problems with them but
they have a lot of power and purpose so
you can use like as an approximator so
it tells you I'm estimating Something
I'm Giving imprecise information on
purpose and that's when we use it
instead of about so if I say he's like
12 years old I could have said he's
about 12 years old it's a one-to-one
shift no one is more meaningless than
the other but simply younger speakers
prefer to do it with like older speakers
prefer about so it's really just a
generational divide in that case we also
find it as a sentence particle and
that's where we just sort of put it in
for some sort of relational information
that it's giving a listener so it's
telling a listener what I'm about to say
is connected in some way to what I just
said and that's usually when you say it
sentence initially so you might say I
don't think I'm going to go to that
party like I'm too tired and that's
where I'm saying I'm going to give you
an example or a reason that's subjective
that gives you more information on what
I just said so it's connecting the two
phrases and the final use is something
we call quotative verb which is be like
so that's when you're using it instead
of the verb to say to give off the sense
that it's not verbatim the verb to say
really implies this verbatimeness to it
it's not really what I'm thinking while
this is happening it's more what I was
saying while this is happening but if I
want to convey to you that I was
thinking something when an event in the
story was happening the verb to say
doesn't allow that kind of subjectivity
but say I am like I was like that allows
that extra piece of information that
this is my subjective interpretation of
events this is my thought process and it
doesn't mislead someone into thinking it
was a Verbatim quote so that's it's
power it does these extra things that we
don't have without that feature in terms
of so there are a couple differences and
some several of them are new in our
speech one is the sentence initial so is
that the one that you were thinking
about yes or or as a transition yeah
it's the same thing everybody's so okay
yeah like so I wonder what you're doing
today a lot I've heard that about that
one a lot I get a lot of emails saying I
hate the so that comes out at the
beginning of the sentence and it's so
funny that people are not there I use
this so it's very their show is
everywhere it's very funny that people
dislike that one because there are so
many different features we use to
connect sentences so if I say something
like therefore thus Hereafter no one
says those are crappy and don't use them
I might not have friends to go drink at
the bar because those sound a little bit
weirdly formal but they are connectors
and so is doing the same kind of work
for some reason people are particularly
opposed to so I think it's because it's
become pretty prevalent but the so there
functions as something called backstory
so so what it does is it tells somebody
oh I just said something or you just
said something and now I need to connect
what I'm going to say to what you said
but I can't jump directly in because
there's a whole back story you need to
know before I get to telling you what
you just asked me and I think people
don't like it because sometimes it seems
like you're going off topic because it's
introducing this backstory but a lot of
times it's because the speaker feels
like that backstory is important to
progressing in in the conversation so it
has a power and a purpose because it's
introducing supplemental material that
otherwise would feel odd without some
sort of indicator by a speaker of what
its purpose is and that's how we all
interpret that so it is amazing to me
how much work these very tiny words do
for us and I appreciate you articulating
just the way these words work I mean
they're almost like Swiss Army knives
that can help us in so many different
situations you brought up a point that I
didn't realize was a pet peeve until I
heard you speaking at the beginning of
phrases before people have even said
anything they'll say I mean and you know
and they haven't said anything so I
don't know what's up with that
a lot of times people say them when
you're in conversation and so I mean is
usually an indicator that you're going
to refine or provide some sort of
additional information on something or
clarify something that was previously
said and it's often something that was
either said several turns ago that you
said or it's something that someone asks
about or someone makes a comment about
that you want to refine their
understanding in terms of interpreting
what you were saying so if someone will
say I mean I didn't really think that
but I guess now that you say it it's
true where it's sort of saying okay yes
I'm stepping back to further explicate
how what I'm saying relates to what
you're saying you know is interesting
because it invites audience inference
that is the idea of you know so when I
say well I was doing this you know and
then this happened what it's doing is
it's involving the listener in a sort of
collective storytelling or Collective
conversation building and that is why I
say you know it's because I want to
involve The Listener in some way in this
collaborative process but because it's
inviting listener inference sometimes
listeners don't interpret it positively
because they feel like you're asking
them to do work it's asking The Listener
to refine their thinking or to do extra
work in thinking when it's not their
turn and I think part of the reason that
people dislike you know is because they
don't want to feel involved at that
level in someone else's turn so it's a
mismatch I think between my attempts to
involve you as a listener in our
conversation collaboratively and your
attempt to be sort of just a static
listener and not have to get involved
all the time it's definitely age driven
I find that discourse markers are tend
to be used more by young women as some
Studies have supported that and older
men in particular find them disfavorable
which can then hurt women in these
professional contexts because that's
underlyingly an evaluation that no one
might be aware they're making but they
may feel like a woman's being less
certain or less sure or less
authoritative because she's inviting
inferences from the audience and we
found though when we look at studies of
who uses these it tends to be people
that on psychological tests prove to be
more conscientious so it seems to be
women because historically they've been
forced to be more the organizers the
conscientious ones the ones that manage
conversation and that makes them more
useful to them you've really opened up
my mind to these phrases that had been
bothersome to me and it strikes me that
you know and I mean are really helping
one of the two functions of language
which is the social emotional aspect of
it and and that research you shared is
fascinating and it certainly highlights
the point that the words we use and the
way we use those words impact how people
see us and what they think about us and
part of the reason why I think what you
study is so important for everybody to
really take time to understand is
judgments are being made about how you
are are using language it's not just are
you communicating your information well
one of the purposes of language but the
impact of that in terms of the
socio-emotional relationship is really
playing out in my world as somebody who
focuses on spoken communication filler
words Loom large the US and the ums they
can be very distracting especially when
repeated too often many people are given
the advice to get rid of these I'm
wondering what is the purpose of them
because they're ubiquitous and do they
help us in some way and to your point
you just made are there differences in
terms of gender age expertise when it
comes to filler words
yes that's a big question so I'm going
to unpack it in a bunch of different
little little levels let's first tackle
the idea of filled pauses which is what
language referred to as Amina which are
slightly different than filler words
more generally from a cognitive
standpoint and also from a function
standpoint so things like you know and
like don't actually pattern in the same
way as uh and um so we when we things
don't pattern the same way we kind of
separate them so Phil pauses are things
that seem to Signal cognitive processing
load so they occur mainly before we're
doing really hard cognitive retrieval so
that means they're going to be more
likely before difficult words more
abstract words less common or familiar
words as well as more hierarchical
intensive syntactic structures what I
mean by that is for example at the very
beginning of a sentence they're going to
occur more often as we find in research
because my brain has to build the entire
structure of the sentence before I get
started and so the um or the uh are
signaling okay I'm really working hard
here so I think it's interesting we hate
them so much when actually they're
signaling someone's doing really hard
work in that conversation and people
that choose very familiar words don't um
as often because they're not doing such
cognitive retrieval now that doesn't
mean they're doing dumb things it simply
means when I do these them I'm really
working hard at coming up with things
are less familiar for me the other thing
is they have a communicative part and so
when I am or uh not only does it signal
I'm doing some hepty cognitive retrieval
but it also signals to a listener that I
need a break I need a pause and I'm not
done with my turn yet because we find
that when people are either giving
lectures or telling stories or talking
to computers all these contacts where
we're not expecting to be interrupted
they um and uh less often which tells us
there's something intentional and
communicative about using those and
since we do it when we're in
conversation more often what that
signals is I'm telling you back off
buddy this is my turn and I just need a
sec and they're really fascinating thing
is when we study what happens after the
Amer the uh we find that ah is preceding
shorter delays than um which suggests
that I'm actually intentional in telling
you as a listener this is going to be
just a second and I'm coming right back
or um means I'm doing more cognitive
work and it's going to take me a little
bit longer so we really seem to Signal
very specific information by our choice
of whether we uh or um and because they
signal cognitive processing load which
generally occurs with new or harder
information
listeners seem to become more attentive
when we use an uh or an um before words
and when we set them up in eye tracking
experiments or with Erp type brain scan
measurements what we find is it
increases their speed at word
recognition and this one is the one that
makes me really impressed it also seems
to help them remember those words that
were preceded by uh or um better than
when they weren't preceded by those in
the tests that we get them later on so
the funny thing to me is how much we
despise I'm in a how much we tell people
to get rid of them when really there's
nothing from a linguistic standpoint
that's not beneficial however from a
social standpoint clearly they're not
well loved and that means people might
perceive you badly when you use them but
I think what we can do in terms of
training ourselves if we're worried
about our arms and us is use the
information that Linguistics can give us
to look at how we can be more effective
speakers from a social standpoint by
taking what we know linguistically and
applying it to our own practice so to do
that we need to make things more
familiar make things less difficult and
make things less abstract because we
know that the more we do that the better
we will be in terms of lowering our rate
of amino so the more I practice and the
more I'm prepared and familiar with my
material the less likely I am in those
contexts to use Amina because the whole
point is I won't need to be doing as
much cognitive activation and so there
are ways that we can use this linguistic
knowledge to help us with our social
knowledge as well there are so many
things that Amina seem to do to really
help us I learned so much from you in
that answer the fact that it signals
cognitive processing which means we're
doing good work on behalf of our
audience and yet the fact that as
audiences we might see the Amina in a
very different light the person's
nervous isn't prepared Etc is
fascinating I'd love for you to talk to
me about how we end our sentences in
terms of vocal quality some of us go up
at the end of our sentences to make them
sound like questions even though they're
not and others of us can get really
quiet or even what's known as this vocal
fry where you get really Gravelly at the
end of sentences
does this serve a purpose at all and is
it Troublesome in terms of language and
language use I think it's only
Troublesome to those that really dislike
it and to the people that are affected
by those who dislike it uh up talk and
vocal fry are both things that have been
strongly associated with women's voices
in Contemporary American culture and
this can be really problematic for women
because women tend to be innovators they
generally lead in language change and
women's voices also historically are not
welcomed in many public forums so when
you take voices that are inherently
biased against anyway and then you make
them innovators and you do noticeable
things like invent new forms and
fashions in speech it doesn't usually go
well for you and that seems to be what's
happening with both up talk and vocal
fry both of those are ways to Signal
social meaning and usually they signal
something about either you want to make
sure people know you're going to
continue your turn so up talk in the way
that you're talking about where it's not
actually a rising International question
but but it's rising intonation on a
statement that has been used primarily
to
signal continuation of a speech stream
and so women might be using this more
often because often they are talked over
so if we look at research particularly
in public domains like professional or
educational settings even though there's
a strong belief women talk more in those
settings they generally do not and in
fact often don't speak up because
they're not treated very well when they
do they don't feel like their voices are
welcome
and so it has made them maybe be a
little more clear that they're not done
with their speaking term because in
those contexts we do find women that
tend to get interrupted more often there
was a really interesting study of
Supreme Court Justices were they found
in oral arguments female Supreme Court
Justices get interrupted at a much
higher rate than male Supreme Court
Justices both by men and women it wasn't
just men doing it it was both groups
just seemed to interrupt women more so
one solution is to rise your
intonational pattern to make sure people
are not misreading your turn is being
done so that's a really effective
strategy it's not Troublesome in the way
that it's actually a very ingenious way
to try to get the turn but it's
Troublesome in that people tend to
really strongly associate this upward
intonation pattern with question
formation and because even though they
know you're not doing a question because
they're very strongly tied to these
Norms of what they think speech should
be used for and international patterns
being one way and not another they often
call attention to it the other one you
talked about was vocal fry which is sort
of the opposite pattern where you drop
in Pitch that seems to signal I'm
getting to the end of my Senate so
that's a totally different cue so
instead of signaling continuation it's
signaling I'm done with my thought and
it does also seem to be something
prevalent in women's speech in the
United States but interestingly if you
look at the studies on vocal fry
historically it tends to be more of a
male feature and it was considered a
hyper masculine feature when studied in
Britain in the 1980s and 1990s and in
fact even in smartphone data that was
called and studied in 2021 to look at
the distribution of vocal fry and
British speech again it was strongly a
male tendency not a female tendency but
what it has really prompted its use here
is again the need for women to adjust
their voice to be taken seriously and we
find a correlation with vocal fry and
ratings of professionalism urbanity and
sort of intimacy and relaxed tone and
that seems to be what's driving young
women to use it these days in America in
speech to get that sort of professional
boost and that competence and Leadership
boost that is associated with low pitch
and men's voices again both of these are
signaling social cues to help people
understand how to relate you've
certainly underscored the power and
Status transfer of information that
comes through the language we use the
words we use but also the way in which
we say it I'd like to switch gears here
and get to two questions that are rather
personal in nature several years ago in
my strategic communication class at the
business school I asked if emojis were
appropriate in business communication
and again several years ago I'd say the
results were about 50 50 from my
students and just recently knowing I was
going to be speaking with you I asked
exactly the same question and the result
was dramatically different uh virtually
everybody said that emojis are
appropriate in business communication as
a linguist what do you think of emojis
are they appropriate in in our community
education are they serving a purpose and
function that words aren't doing for us
I think they absolutely are there have
been some studies in the early 2000s on
texting speech or computer mediated
communication and they looked at things
like emojis and they found that they
were actually quite rare at that time
they were only about four percent of our
Communications in that Forum but I think
you're right that in the last 15 years
or so it has grown exponentially how
much we use those kinds of meta
messaging in our texts and our emails
and I think that's because there has
been such an explosion especially with
the pandemic that even before that with
our our forms of communication in the
workplace we have gone from
communicating over the phone and face to
face to communicating primarily over
email and text I have two teenagers and
I don't think they even know how to use
a phone I'm not kidding my younger son
yelled at me for calling him on the
phone I'm like that's what it's for he's
like no no no this is a texting device
exactly so it has shifted so
dramatically how much we use these
different kinds of techniques of getting
in touch but what the problem is when
you're not face to face is the
communication of all these social
messages that we give when we talk on
the phone or we talk face to face are
not available to us and things can be
misconstrued so if you say what are you
doing well when we're in person I might
say what are you doing well and that's
clear from my intonation that you're
doing something wrong but if I say hey
what you doing that's clear from my tone
a voice that I'm just like what's going
on let's hang out so very very different
things for the exact same words but when
you're on a text or an email that kind
of social messaging isn't available to
you but what is are these other new
forms of transmitting these emotional
and social messages and emojis are huge
in that and they're more effective in
many ways than some of the things like
exclamation points in all caps because
there's so many different forms of them
that you can convey all sorts of
emotions so irony laughter love all of
those things are available and
accessible now I I don't think I would
suggest sending your boss a heart emoji
is maybe the right choice but certainly
I think if you say something and you
want it to be taken tongue-in-cheek or
as sort of I don't want to be
confrontational here I'm trying to just
convey information like I need that
report by five I'm not yelling at you
I'm just requesting and there's no way
to indicate that unless you use
additional information so I might yell
at you by writing all caps but if I'm
just conveying that I need that report
by five and hey we're cool a smiley face
can do a lot of that kind of work for us
so I absolutely think it's fine but I
also think this is a case where you need
to know your audience and if you know
that you have a you know curmudgeon as a
boss that probably has never used an
emoji in his life that wouldn't be the
best choice to use one with him you just
need to be very careful in your wording
not to come across as to direct or as
somewhat rude which I think email often
can be a forum where that can happen
easily I predict that if you and I were
to have this this conversation five ten
years from now that sending your boss a
heart emoji might be acceptable it is
changing so quickly and so fast that
evolution is going to happen I'm
convinced I do agree that the subtle
cues that you can put in through emojis
are really helpful and can help reduce
friction and misunderstanding now this
question is incredibly personal as a
linguist I'd love to get your take on
the very ungrammatical name of this
podcast think fast talk smart do we get
a failing grade in a from a linguist
oh no you definitely get an A plus
well first of all it's really not
ungrammatical so if we were outside in
Tahoe and 20 feet of snow and I threw a
snowball at you and I said think fast it
would be completely appropriate so it's
not really ungrammatical if you
situationally place it but what I love
is how you're using one of the first
lessons of marketing and branding which
is make yourself memorable and if we are
all saying the same thing then saying
something different makes it stand out
and so it's a very effective way to make
a name or a title be different uh Stand
Out have more marketing and branding
value because it's more memorable when
it's not just the same old same old and
by doing something slightly atypical you
are making people notice it more so I I
love the name well thank you for that so
Valerie before we end I would love to
ask you the same three questions that I
ask everybody and I'm going to be very
curious about the words you choose
because I know words are so important to
you if you were to capture the best
communication advice you ever received
as a five to seven word presentation
slide title what would it be
sometimes listening is more important
than speaking okay that was some great
advice I got when I first became an
academic I joined my department as a
tenure track professor and as anybody
who's in a university knows tenure is
one of those things where everybody who
votes on you or is your colleague so you
have to be very diplomatic and very
careful and I asked a mentor I had what
her advice was for how I should approach
conversations with my colleagues
participation in departmental meetings
and that was some really good advice she
said listening is sometimes more
important than speaking because a lot of
people want to hear themselves talk but
very few people want to answer the
questions they're asked and if you take
the time to listen to what people need
from you you'll be a much more effective
speaker and a much more effective
teacher and I think that really has paid
off over the years in in my classes and
in my interactions with people well your
advice there and the advice you were
given is really important listening is I
think the most important part of
communication in clear really somebody
who does what you do you've demonstrated
throughout our conversation that you
listen very astutely not just for the
meaning but for the the use of words and
how it plays out question number two who
is a communicator that you admire and
why
now this is a tough one because I'm torn
between
ones that I you know historically have
had a lot of respect for and ones that I
think are great communicators in the
modern era in ways that people would not
expect so am I allowed to I'll give you
two I'm very curious now you've teased
me okay so I think if I was just going
to say who's a great orator and who I
feel has a wonderful Cadence and an
emotional resonance in the way he talks
that has been appealing to many many
people I'd say Martin Luther King of
course you cannot Listen to I have a
dream without feeling like you have a
dream and there is this dream it so it
captures you it's the Cadence it's such
a clear message I don't think many
people would argue that he was a great
communicator but I think young women in
the modern era in terms of their ability
to be great communicators and really
resonate with an audience which may not
be the audience people want them to
resonate with but the audience that they
intend to resonate with and who they
reach the most I would say Taylor Swift
is actually a great communicator I I
think a lot of people don't give her
credit for that she has an incredible
influence on young people and young
women in particular and she's also very
eloquent but she's also using the norms
and the functions and the features of
today's young women so she really
resonates and reverberates with that
group and I think that's really the mark
of an affected speaker I think you
picked two very very effective speakers
very very different audiences very very
different times but but both leveraging
many of the things you've talked about
the way in which words are constructed
and used to get attention and get
messages across all right final question
question number three what are the first
three ingredients that go into a
successful communication recipe
to listen well second to respond kindly
and compassionately and third to relax
everything you're worried about in
speech of people that may not talk like
you will work itself out and it'll
become our new Norms or they'll be on
the Wayside and it's not going to cause
the decay of English so I think relax
would be my third word in that case and
I think that is really important advice
you know I do a lot of work and I'm sure
you do as well with non-native speakers
in our case to English and there's a lot
of stress to say it right you know
whatever that right is and to relax and
understand that there is some give in
language and that it will change over
time is really important well Valerie
thank you so much I have to admit that
speaking to a linguist I was very
worried about my word choice and you
made it very comfortable and natural to
speak with you and we learned a lot
about not just the purpose of language
in terms of transmission of meaning but
of transmitting connection and social
relationships and how all of these
things came to be thank you so much
absolutely thank you for having me on
thank you
[Applause]
thanks for joining us for another
episode of think fast talk smart the
podcast from Stanford Graduate School of
Business this episode was produced by
Jenny Luna Ryan Campos and me Matt
Abrahams our music was provided by Floyd
Wonder for more information and episodes
find us on YouTube or wherever you get
your podcasts thank you and please make
sure to subscribe and follow us on
LinkedIn